In order to understand social cognitive theories of personality, let's just
look at this graph of two hypothetical people. A and B. So the basic idea is
that these two people bring different interpretations to each situation. In
this case, nine different situations. So on the horizontal axis, we have these
social factors or the situation. And on the vertical axis, we have the
probability that the person will act in a certain way, in this case, hostility.
So overall you can see, this profile, that person A acts more hostility than
person B in many of the situations. But not all. And if you took an average
across all situations, person A would be more hostile than person B. So, social
cognitive explanations of personality therefore argue that behavior is a result
of this interaction. Between the personal and that is cognitive believes and
the social, that is the situational factors, that is between internal and
external forces. Some different people bring different beliefs and
interpretations to each situation and therefore have different personalities.